sie gehören zum Schönsten was Künstler
Genies in der Geschichte der Menschheit
erschaffen haben Gemälde von Van Gogh
oder Claude Monet und dann kommen
klimarevoluzzer wie Sie Miriam Hermann
aus Passau ich war das verkündet sie auf
Twitter nachdem sie Kartoffelbrei über
ein Werk von Claude Monet verschüttet
hat sie protzt vor Stolz wir schütteln
fassungslos den Kopf über schmiriam aus
der Preis society
eine fanatische Predigt zum
vermeintlichen klima-untergang ein mehr
als 100 Millionen Euro teures Gemälde
geschändet beschmiert von ihr Mirjam
Herrmann 25 Jahre alt sogenannte
klimareterin und Mitglied der letzten
Generation
radikaler klimaaktivismus steht bei der
25-Jährigen Jura-Studentin an der
Tagesordnung Samstag 22 Oktober ein Tag
vor Miriam Hermanns Kartoffelbrei
Attacke das Verkehrsministerium in
Berlin mit selbstgebastelten
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungsschildern
verbarrikadieren sogenannte
klimaaktivisten den Eingang zum
Bundesministerium sie fordern ein
Tempolimit eine der klimakaoten Mirjam
Herrmann und haben jetzt übergangsweise
diese plastikschüler hier bereitgestellt
ich glaube das sollte auch reichen
dass ich einmal die Menschen ein
bisschen dran gewöhnt haben brauchen wir
eigentlich gar keine Schilder mehr weil
dann ist jahrhundert klar das ist die
Höchsttemperatur die Höchsttemperatur
sage ich schon die Höchsttempo ist
ziemlich viel los an einem Wochenende
viel los im Leben einer vorzeige
klimakaoten fanatisch radikal schamlos
doch Miriam Hermanns Lebenslauf liest
sich eigentlich eher wie Jetset als
jetzt oder nicht schon in der Schule
verbringt sie einen Auslandsjahr im
Sunshine State Californien später
studiert die radikale klimaaktivistin in
Jerusalem und London arbeitet für eine
Wohltätigkeitsorganisation in Tansania
inzwischen studiert die 25-Jährige Jura
an der Universität Passau liegt jedoch
momentan eine klimaaktivistische Pause
ein mit der Bahn wird Miriam Hermann all
ihre Lebensstationen wahrscheinlich
nicht erreicht haben
nach dem süßen Leben der Unbeschwertheit
und des umherreisens wird mit Mirjam
Herrmann sich dann Vollzeit der
vermeintlichen Rettung des Klimas ihr
social Media ist voll von Post zu über
Radikale klimaaktivisten und Aufständen
stolz postet sie unter anderem dieses
Video um gegen die internationale
Automobilmesse im Jahr 2021 zu
protestieren hängt sich die 25-Jährige
von einer Autobahnbrücke bringt sich und
vor allem anderen Lebensgefahr
fassungslos ist Mirjam Herrmann danach
über ihre Festnahme und ihren
fünftägigen Gefängnisaufenthalt ich habe
es einfach nicht für möglich gehalten
das kam mir einfach übertrieben vor ich
dachte nicht dass das realistisch ist
dass dass ich in Deutschland für sowas
ins Gefängnis gehe wo ich von keiner
keiner Straftat verurteilt bin wo ich
was gemacht habe was noch nicht mal klar
eine Straftat ist fassungslos ist auch
die Staatsanwaltschaft München die
fordert bis zu vier Jahre Haft für diese
Aktion doch die radikale klimaaktivistin
lässt sich davon nicht aus der Ruhe
bringen brisant 8 Tage vor ihrer
Kartoffelbrei Attacke auf Monet teilt
mir ja mal Hermann noch diesen Tweet
über den tomatensuppenwurf auf van Gogh
in London okay hören sie mir zu das war
wirklich eine visionäre und inspirierte
Aktion
inspiriert wurde auch Miriam Hermann
eine Woche später schmeißt sie selbst
Lebensmittel auf ein einzigartiges
Kunstwerk die Welt zu bereisen war der
klimakaote nicht genug jetzt meint
Miriam Hermann die Welt retten zu müssen
koste es was es wolle
ja mit was für Menschen haben wir es
hier zu tun und wie können wir dem
überhaupt noch Einhalt gebieten viele
Fragen die uns umtreiben und die wir
jetzt mit kolumnest und Autor Jan
Fleischhauer besprechen herzlich
willkommen
nach Berlin Herr Fleischhauer viele
haben den Eindruck die selbst genannten
Klimaschützer sind oft gut gebildete
weitgereiste junge Menschen aus
gutsituierten Verhältnissen die den
normalen Menschen die sich morgens
machen kann es nicht anders sagen zur
Arbeit schleppen den Weg versperren wie
sehen Sie das
dran also wenn eine Umfrage machen
würden
unter einer klimaaktivisten die da in
Berlin immer an der Autobahn stehen oder
auf der Autobahn auf der Straße sich
angeklebt haben also die zarten
Arbeiterkinder mit der relativ gering
sein
kennt man ja auch aus der Geschichte
also die diejenigen die ins Kloster
geschickt waren wurden war die höheren
Töchtern
erinnert mich daran
wenn wir mal ich meine sich für den
Klima einsetzen ist ja generell eine
gute Sache die Art und Weise wie sie das
tun verurteile ich wirklich sehr scharf
wenn schon festkleben wo würde es denn
ihrer Meinung nach Sinn ergeben
na gut sind da gibt es schon also wir
berichten heute hier darüber und reden
darüber ne es war also diese diese
Kartoffelbrei Attacke habe ich also
überall auf Twitter gesehen und auf
allen sozialen Kanälen also beim
Aufmerksamkeit für seine Sache erreichen
will
ist doch ein probates Mittel also ich
muss natürlich jetzt immer wenn ich
keine Freezer Neubau demnächst sehe aber
Lanz an den Kartoffelbrei denken weil
auch Luise Neubauer findet das ja im
Prinzip richtig also auch für last
generation hat sie sich ausgesprochen
und bevor sie dann ihre ganzen Instagram
Profile geklingt hat und gesäubert war
sie natürlich auch eine von diesen
vielfliegen wie diese Miriam die Sie
gerade beschrieben haben aber die halten
es persönlich auch für richtig dass man
Kartoffelbrei auf money wirft
ich weiß nicht was das sicherlich eine
als eine Straftat ist aber also
jedenfalls den Strafrahmen würde ich mal
als als Staatsanwalt hier mal
ausschöpfen also wenn schon denn schon
also ist ja wie auch bei dieser Kleberei
auf der Straße mich wundert immer ein
bisschen die
Nachsichtigkeit ja mit denen mit der in
Berlin darauf reagiert wird hat ja
möglicherweise auch einen guten Grund
warum das im Wesentlichen in Berlin
stattfindet zum Beispiel nicht in
München da kaum in München
weil also ich glaube in München wenn man
das hier auf mittlere Drink veranstalten
würde und nicht nur einmal sondern
mehrmals
obwohl wir eine SPD regierte Stadt sind
da gilt dann schon bayerische Härte also
dann kommt irgendwann die Reiterstaffel
vorbei und dann ist der Spuk vor zu Ende
so also
ja ich finde natürlich müsste man dann
auch schon mal die Leuten zeigen so
geht's nicht
auf der einen Seite beschweren sich ja
die klimakaoten wie ich sie jetzt mal
nenne darüber das Klimaveränderungen
Hunger in der Welt erzeugen dann
schmeißen sie aber mit Kartoffelbrei und
Tomatensuppe um sich und wenn dann bei
VW nachts das Licht ausgeschaltet wird
um Energie zu sparen jammern die
Protestler am Ende haben wir es hier mit
einer Doppelmoral zu tun
ja mit Doppelmoral also mit jedenfalls
interessanten Widersprüchen ne also die
die jetzt wieder im Bild sehen das sind
ja irgendwelche
wissenschaftsaktivisten ne
die da bei der Porsche sich angeklebt
haben und dann hat Porsche relativ cool
reagiert und hat das Licht auszustellen
ich glaube die Heizung und worauf wonach
zuerst gerufen wurde von der Heizung was
natürlich eine Komik hat also wenn ich
sozusagen für die dekarbonisierung bin
ja und gegen das fossile das erste dann
aber einfordere
Heizung also fossile Brennstoffe
so insofern hat in diesem Fall Porsche
mal den klimaaktivisten ausgekontert
ja also ich glaube man manchmal wie ein
Verdacht das ist im Ernst von der von
allgemeiner Agentur der Ölindustrie
heimlich bezahlt ja um die
klimaschutzbewegung bei so richtig jetzt
ein Weib zu Polen und die komplette
Lächerlichkeit preiszugeben und ich habe
ja auch auf diese Kartoffelbrei hat
danke so ein bisschen die Reaktionen
gesehen also selbst im linken Lager hat
das kaum noch jemand verteidigen wollen
und alle haben den Kopf geschüttelten
die Augen zugehalten haben gesagt im
Gottes Willen wie peinlich ist denn das
ne danke Jan Fleischhauer für diese
Einschätzung
[Musik]